What could be more American than the person who sees something they've never done before, dreams they could do it, goes after that dream? Well, let's begin today with a woman who dreams of directing a play in the small town where she lives, a college town somewhere below the Mason-Dixon line in the hills of Appalachia, a town which will remain, for our purposes today, unnamed.
还有什么比一个人看到从未做过的事情，梦想着自己能做到，然后去追求那个梦想更具美国特色呢？那么，今天我们从一位女士开始讲起，她梦想在自己居住的小镇导演一出戏，那是一个位于梅森-迪克森线以南、阿巴拉契亚山脉中的大学城，为了我们今天的目的，这个小镇将保持匿名。
I don't think she'd ever directed. And she claimed to have acted. And it was never really quite clear just what her credentials were. But she had managed to convince the local theater department of this college that she should direct a production of Peter Pan.
我想她以前从未导演过。她声称自己演过戏。对于她到底有什么资历，从来没有真正明确过。但她设法说服了这所大学当地的戏剧系，让她导演一出《彼得·潘》。
When he was in the 10th grade in 1973, Jack Hitt saw her production. And like everybody else in town, he heard about it for weeks beforehand.
1973年，杰克·希特（Jack Hitt）上十年级时，观看了她的演出。和镇上的其他人一样，他在演出前几周就听说过这件事。
Slowly but surely, you began to hear sort of rumors about this production. For example, I know that they had spent a lot of money renting these flying apparatuses out of New York. And apparently, there's, like, one company and a handful of these apparatuses. So to get them was a major coup.
慢慢地，你开始听到关于这部戏的一些传言。例如，我知道他们花了很多钱从纽约租来了这些飞行装置。显然，好像只有一家公司有那么几套这样的装置。所以能弄到它们是一次重大的出击。
This is a story not just of a mediocre play or a terrible play. When it comes right down to it, it's not even a story about a play. This is a story about a fiasco and about what makes a fiasco. And one ingredient of many fiascoes is that great, massive, heart-wrenching chaos and failure are more likely to occur when great ambition has come into play, when plans are big, expectations great, hopes at their highest.
这不仅是一个关于平庸之作或糟糕作品的故事。归根结底，这甚至不是一个关于戏剧的故事。这是一个关于惨败的故事，以及是什么造就了一场惨败。许多惨败的一个共同要素是，当巨大的野心发挥作用，当计划宏大、期望极高、希望达到巅峰时，巨大的、毁灭性的、令人心碎的混乱和失败就更有可能发生。
And what you have to understand is that everybody in this sort of community understood that there was certainly a sort of air of everyone reaching beyond their own grasp. Every actor was in a role that was just a little too big for them, every aspect of the set and the crew.
你需要明白的是，这个社区里的每个人都明白，当时确实有一种每个人都在做力所不能及之事的气氛。每个演员扮演的角色都比他们能胜任的稍微大了一点，布景和剧组的每一个方面也都是如此。
And rumors had cooked around. There was this huge crew. There were lots of things being painted.
传言四起。剧组规模庞大。有许多东西在进行喷绘。
See, but this, in fact, is one of the criteria for greatness, that everyone is just about to reach just beyond their grasp, because that is when greatness can occur.
看，但这其实是伟大的标准之一，每个人都正要触及他们力所不能及的边缘，因为那是伟大可能发生的时候。
That's right. That's right. And maybe greatness could have occurred.
没错。没错。也许伟大本可能发生。
Well, today on our program, what happens when greatness does not occur. What happens, in fact, when fumble leads to error leads to mishap, and before you know it, you have left the realm of ordinary mistake and chaos, and you have entered into the more ethereal, specialized realm of fiasco. Today's show, Fiascoes, a philosophical inquiry-- perhaps the first ever, as far as we know-- into what makes a fiasco, what takes our ordinary lives the extra distance into fiasco.
那么，今天在我们的节目中，当伟大没有发生时会怎样。事实上，当失误导致错误导致事故，在你不经意间，你已经离开了普通错误和混乱的领域，进入了一个更空灵、更专门的“惨败”领域。今天的节目《惨败》，是一次哲学探讨——据我们所知，这可能是史上首次——探讨是什么造就了一场惨败，是什么让我们的平凡生活多走了一段路，陷入了惨败。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program in four acts. Act One, Opening Night. Act Two, a fiasco involving a village, marauding Visigoths, a 1,9000-pound brass cauldron, and some oil. Don't even ask. Act Three, Squirrel Cop, in which a bushy-tailed visitor threatens to take down two police officers, a married couple, a couch, and a house. Act Four, Fiascoes as a Force for Good in this World.
来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目分四幕。第一幕，首演之夜。第二幕，一场涉及一个村庄、劫掠的西哥特人、一口1900磅重的黄铜大锅和一些油的惨败。别问了。第三幕，松鼠警察，一只毛茸茸的访客威胁要搞定两名警官、一对夫妇、一张沙发和一个房子。第四幕，惨败作为这个世界的一种向善力量。
There is much, much to learn about fiascoes in this hour. Stay with us.
在这个小时里，关于惨败有很多很多值得学习的地方。请留在我们身边。
We begin our show with this true fable of Peter Pan in Act One, Opening Night.
我们以第一幕《首演之夜》中关于《彼得·潘》的真实寓言开始我们的节目。
Opening night comes, and, well, almost everybody in the area, in the 10-mile radius of this theater, knows somebody in this production. So the place is pretty much packed. And I don't know if you remember the opening moment of Peter Pan, but it's the three little kids sleeping in their bed. And Peter Pan comes flying in the window.
首演之夜到了，嗯，这个剧院方圆10英里内的几乎每个人都认识这部戏里的某个人。所以剧场几乎挤满了人。我不知道你是否还记得《彼得·潘》的开场，是三个小孩子躺在床上睡觉。然后彼得·潘从窗户飞了进来。
And in this particular production, there's a big bed with all the three kids in it. And off to the left, I remember, is a big, huge wardrobe. And there's a large window there, and a little bureau. And Peter Pan comes in and has the little speech where he says, "Anybody can fly. Why, with just a little magic dust, one can fly." And Peter Pan sprinkles this magic dust in the air.
在这场特定的演出中，有一张大床，三个孩子都在上面。在左边，我记得有一个大大的衣柜。那里有一扇大窗户，还有一个小梳妆台。彼得·潘进来后说了那段话：“任何人都会飞。只要有一点魔法粉末，人就能飞。”然后彼得·潘把这些魔法粉末撒在空中。
And sure enough, the kids suddenly just lurch into the air. And it becomes clear right away that the people that they've hired to run these flying apparatuses really aren't quite clear on how they actually work. So instead of the kids sailing gracefully to and fro, they hang in the air like puppets, just dangling there and getting jerked up an inch or two or back and forth.
果然，孩子们突然就冲向了空中。立刻变得很明显，他们雇来操作这些飞行装置的人根本不清楚它们实际上是怎么工作的。所以，孩子们并没有优雅地飞来飞去，而是像木偶一样挂在空中，就在那里晃悠，被生硬地向上拽一两英寸，或者左右摇摆。
And then sometimes they're just stationary?
有时他们就静止不动了？
Yeah. Just hanging there like a spider.
是的。就像蜘蛛一样挂在那里。
And then several of them start to circumscribe these circles in the air, where it's clear that the people running the machines have just set them off on these oval courses that spiral farther and farther out. And if you're sitting in the audience, there was clearly a sense of fear on the faces of these people.
然后其中几个人开始在空中画圆圈，很明显操作机器的人只是把他们设置在这些椭圆形的轨道上，然后螺旋着越转越远。如果你坐在观众席上，可以清楚地感觉到这些人脸上的恐惧。
Of the actors?
演员的恐惧？
The actors. The actors actually-- you could sense their lack of confidence, shall we say, in the people running the machines in the back.
演员的。演员们实际上——你可以感觉到他们对后面操作机器的人缺乏信心，我们可以这么说。
Wait, wait. And the audience reaction to this point is just-- are they laughing?
等等，等等。那观众到目前为止的反应是——他们在笑吗？
No one is laughing. This is one of the great things about audiences, especially in a live theater production, is that they're very forgiving. They want the show to work. And so everyone is gripping their chair a little tightly. We feel for them. They're up there. They're embarrassing themselves for us.
没有人笑。这是现场戏剧演出中观众最伟大的地方之一，就是他们非常宽容。他们希望演出成功。所以每个人都把椅子抓得紧紧的。我们同情他们。他们在上面。他们在为我们出丑。
We identify with them. We become them.
我们认同他们。我们变成了他们。
And so the audience, I think, was very forgiving and very understanding of this moment. But there was one moment in this first opening scene that put the audience on notice. And that's when, as the kids are jerking up and down and swinging back and forth and going around in these ovals, at one point, the littlest one, the little boy, is being flung around a little too hard.
所以我认为，观众当时非常宽容，对这一刻非常理解。但在第一场开幕戏中有一个时刻让观众警觉了。那就是，当孩子们上下晃动、左右摆动并沿着这些椭圆形飞行时，有一次，那个最小的男孩子被甩得太厉害了。
Well, he has the least mass to resist whatever the machinery is doing to him.
嗯，他的体重最小，最难抵抗机器对他做出的动作。
Right.
对。
Mm-hm. OK. So, and?
嗯。好的。然后呢？
And so he's flying around in this circle. And the audience sees this coming. And there's a real sense of pain and gripping of the chair and white knuckle-ness as the kid suddenly does just an enormous splat into the wardrobe. And it's clear that he's hurt, and he comes off of it a little dazed. Then, of course, he's jerked up in the air a little bit, and often a little too high, so that he's suddenly in the workings. He left the stage itself. He's now up there with the lights. Then, all of a sudden he would just plummet back down to the stage and be caught up just before he hit the floor.
所以他在那个圆圈里飞着。观众看到了这一幕。当那个孩子突然猛地撞在衣柜上时，人们有一种真正的痛苦感，抓紧了椅子，指关节发白。很明显他受伤了，他从衣柜上滑下来时有点晕头转向。然后，当然，他又被猛地拽到空中，通常是拽得太高了，以至于他突然进入了机器运作区。他离开了舞台本身。他现在在那上面，和灯光在一起。然后，突然间他会猛地坠落回舞台，就在快要撞到地板时被钩住。
It was hard to watch, because, as you can tell, it's an incredibly funny moment, but like I say, the audience was still in this very forgiving mode. And no one said a word. We just all sat there, holding our breath. And there's that weird tension of being in the audience, thinking, oh, oh my goodness. They have gotten off to a very bad start. Oh, this is not good. And we feel for them.
看的时候很难受，因为如你所知，这是一个极其滑稽的时刻，但就像我说的，观众当时仍然处于那种非常宽容的状态。没有人说一句话。我们都坐在那里，屏住呼吸。而且在观众席里有一种奇怪的紧张感，心想，哦，哦，天哪。他们开局非常糟糕。哦，这不太好。我们同情他们。
May I just interrupt for just a moment to just say, now at this point-- because after all, we are not just joined here together on the radio, you and I today, to laugh at the foibles of the unfortunate. No, no. We're here to enumerate the qualities of a fiasco. At this point, we are not yet in the territory of fiasco.
我可以打断一下吗，现在这个节点——因为毕竟，我们今天聚在电台里不是为了嘲笑不幸者的怪癖。不，不。我们在这里是为了列举惨败的特质。在这一点上，我们还没有进入惨败的领域。
No. No, because, like I say, audiences are forgiving. One or two mistakes, even big ones like this, they are going to let that ride.
不。不，因为就像我说的，观众是宽容的。一两次错误，即使是像这样的大错误，他们也会放过。
Yes, they are.
是的，他们会。
We did. We did. We were very good.
我们做到了。我们做到了。我们表现得很好。
So we are not yet at fiasco. We are at a normal level of mishap.
所以我们还没有到达惨败。我们处于正常的事故水平。
Right. What happens immediately after this, they disappear to Never Never Land. And if you remember, the stage goes dark. And then when the lights come up, there's Captain Hook. And he's giving his first opening soliloquy about how evil he is and what a menace he is and how he harms people and hates children. It's all that good stuff.
对。紧接着发生的事情是，他们消失去了“梦幻岛”。如果你还记得，舞台变暗了。然后当灯光亮起时，胡克船长出现了。他正在发表他那段开场独白，讲述他是多么邪恶，他是一个多么大的威胁，他如何伤害他人，如何痛恨儿童。都是那些好戏码。
And so Captain Hook is out there, and he looks great. He's got one of those big, old, fat hats and this great hook and these wild-looking boots and everything.
所以胡克船长在舞台上，他看起来很棒。他戴着那种又大又旧的肥帽子，还有那根很棒的钩子和这些看起来很狂野的靴子等等。
And people are feeling more confident. Something's happening.
人们开始感到更有信心了。事情正在好转。
It's a good sign. It's a good sign. And he's in charge. This guy, he's got a bad mustache, and he is certainly evil. And the audience is totally in his pocket. He's speaking away and gesturing wildly and going on and on about how bad he is.
这是一个好迹象。这是一个好迹象。他掌控着全局。这家伙，他留着一脸坏相的小胡子，他确实很邪恶。观众完全被他吸引住了。他正在大声说着，疯狂地做着手势，不停地吹嘘自己有多坏。
And then at a certain point, as he gestures, his hook and the entire black casing up to his elbow flings off of his hand and flies into the audience and punches an old lady in the gut.
然后在某个时刻，当他做手势时，他的钩子和整个延伸到他手肘的黑色外壳从手上飞了出去，飞向观众席，重重地打在一位老太太的肚子上。
He is bad.
他确实很坏。
He is very bad. He had the worst ad lib I've ever heard. I mean, what do you say at that point? Because, of course, his hand is now nakedly exposed to the audience.
他非常坏。他说了我听过最糟糕的即兴台词。我是说，在那一刻你能说什么？因为当然，他的手现在赤裸裸地暴露在观众面前了。
A tough moment for any actor.
对任何演员来说都是艰难的时刻。
Very, very hard.
非常非常困难。
If the very premise of your character is that you have a hook, your name is Captain Hook, literally all that's going to happen for the rest of the show is people are going to refer to you by that hook. Your entire motivation as a character is the fact that your arm was eaten off by an alligator and that you have to have a hook.
如果你的角色的前提就是你有一只钩子，你的名字叫胡克船长，字面意思上，整场戏剩下的时间里，人们只会通过那只钩子来指代你。你作为一个角色的全部动机就是你的手臂被鳄鱼吃掉了，所以你必须有一只钩子。
The entire plot stems from that fact.
整个剧情都源于这个事实。
Right. And now, suddenly, you have no hook.
对。现在，突然之间，你没有钩子了。
In fact, you have five fingers on a hand.
事实上，你的手上长着五根手指。
As if a miracle by the Lord.
仿佛上帝的奇迹。
Captain Hook said, "You know, they just don't make those hooks like they used to." That was actually the ad lib. I will never forget it. Then the lights come up, and we are in Never Never Land.
胡克船长说：“你知道，他们制作钩子的质量大不如前了。”这实际上就是那句即兴台词。我永远不会忘记它。然后灯光亮起，我们来到了梦幻岛。
In Act Two.
在第二幕。
Yeah, this is Act Two. And Captain Hook might have stood in front of the set, but you didn't really see it, because he spoke from shadow. And now the lights come up. And this is supposed to be a very dramatic moment.
是的，这是第二幕。胡克船长可能站在布景前，但你并没有真正看清它，因为他在阴影中说话。现在灯光亮起了。这本该是一个非常戏剧性的时刻。
The rumors of all this crew and the painting and everything that was going on and all this construction all worked towards this one moment, because when the lights came up, here was Never Never Land, this sort of psychedelic set. There were papier-mache mushrooms everywhere of different sizes. It was absolutely wonderful and surreal.
关于这个剧组、绘画、施工以及所有正在发生的事情的传言，都指向了这一刻，因为当灯光亮起时，这就是梦幻岛，一种迷幻的场景。到处都是不同大小的纸糊蘑菇。它绝对美妙而超现实。
And there's nobody there. And then from the upper rafters of stage right, suddenly the kids and Peter Pan appear.
那里没有人。然后从舞台右侧上方的横梁上，孩子们和彼得·潘突然出现了。
Flying.
飞着。
Flying. They're flying. And their landing occurs rather rapidly, at an angle of about 45 degrees to the stage. They come down basically like, I don't know, lead sinkers on a line, and crash to the floor, and then are just dragged across the floor like mops and wipe out all of the mushrooms.
飞着。他们正在飞行。他们的着陆相当迅速，以大约45度的角度撞向舞台。他们基本就像……我不知道，像线上的铅坠一样降下来，然后摔在地板上，接着就像拖把一样被拖过地板，把所有的蘑菇都扫平了。
And so now, have we arrived at a turning point in our fiasco?
那么现在，我们到达了惨败的转折点了吗？
Yeah. Yeah, it's clear now that the audience is giving way. Something has been lost. Some sense of decorum, that little bit of forgiveness that the audience has for the actors--
是的。是的，现在很明显观众正在放弃。有些东西已经丢失了。某种礼仪感，观众对演员的那一点点宽容——
And empathy.
还有同理心。
--and empathy. It's beginning to dissipate. Well, there was a split in the audience. The younger people, who were the least forgiving, they started to go first. OK, so the high school students, a couple of college students, maybe, they started to laugh out loud.
——还有同理心。它开始消散了。嗯，观众出现了分歧。年轻人，他们最不宽容，他们先开始爆发了。好吧，所以高中生，可能还有几个大学生，他们开始大声笑了出来。
And I'll be honest, Ira, I might have been one of those first people to laugh. I was in the 10th grade. It was hard to not laugh at this thing. But then, whatever restraint that the audience had, it just evaporated at this point, because there were a number of things that happened in quick succession that just made it impossible to hold any sense of decorum.
老实说，艾拉，我可能就是那些最早笑出来的人之一。我上十年级。很难不笑出声来。但随后，观众原本所有的克制在这一刻蒸发了，因为在很短的时间内发生了一系列事情，让人根本无法保持任何礼仪感。
Which are?
是哪些？
For example, Tinker Bell appears for the first time around this moment. And Tinker Bell is essentially a light bulb on an extension cord.
例如，奇妙仙子（小叮当）在这一刻左右第一次出现。而奇妙仙子本质上就是一个连在延长线上的灯泡。
What?
什么？
Yeah. And this was the director's idea of being raw, being very modern. Tinker Bell was just going to be this literal light bulb, dangling from an extension cord.
是的。这是导演心目中“原始”、“非常现代”的构思。奇妙仙子就只是这个连在延长线上的字面意义上的灯泡。
Whereas, in other productions, what they'll do is that someone will shine a light.
而其他制作中，他们通常会用光去照。
Shine a light, or they'll just--
用光照，或者他们只是——
A beam of focused light. And then that pinprick of light is supposed to be Tinker Bell.
一道聚焦的光束。然后那一小点光被认为是奇妙仙子。
That's right, or something like that, or nothing at all, and people just address the invisible sprite. Well, that did not happen in this case. This bulb comes just dangling down and sort of hangs around this naked--
没错，或者类似的东西，要么什么都没有，人们只是对着看不见的精灵说话。嗯，在这个案例中并没有那样。这个灯泡只是晃晃悠悠地垂下来，悬浮在这个赤裸的——
A bare light bulb?
一个光秃秃的灯泡？
--white bulb just hangs around. And people are talking to it. And I think Tinker Bell must have had an appearance in the first act. But it was somewhere in here that people just started laughing at this.
——白色的灯泡就这样悬着。人们在跟它说话。我想奇妙仙子在第一幕一定出场过。但就是在这里，人们开始笑话这个了。
Then another thing that happened was, later on in this scene, if you remember, Wendy gets trapped on an island. And she spots a kite that's flying by. And she's supposed to grab it and attach it to her back and fly off. Well, of course, the kite is attached to the flying apparatus line. And it gets closer and closer to her. She's standing on this little papier-mache hill.
然后发生的另一件事是，在这一幕的后面，如果你记得，温迪被困在一个岛上。她发现一只风筝飞过。她本该抓住它，把它系在背上飞走。嗯，当然，风筝被系在飞行装置的线上。它离她越来越近。她站在那个纸糊的小山上。
But the flying apparatus people can't quite get it close enough to her to reach. So she has to step out into the waters that she's just told us is filled with crocodiles to grab it. She finally gets the kite, and when she yanks on it, it pops off the flying apparatus. And the hook goes zinging up into the lights and catches.
但飞行装置的操作人员无法让它靠近到她能触及的距离。所以她不得不走下水，而她刚才才告诉我们水里充满了鳄鱼，去抓那个风筝。她终于抓住了风筝，当她用力一拉时，它从飞行装置上弹了出来。钩子呼啸着飞向上方的灯光并挂住了。
So now there is this big loop of wire hanging in front of the stage. And there's Wendy, holding the kite. And she ad libbed as best she could, as I remember. She said, "On second thought, maybe I can swim." And with that, she walked off the stage, motioning her arms like you would do the swim, the dance, in 1965.
所以现在舞台前方挂着一大圈电线。温迪拿着风筝，据我记得，她尽力即兴发挥了。她说：“再想想，也许我可以游泳。”说完，她走下舞台，手臂做着动作，就像你在1965年做那种游泳舞一样。
So she does that. At this point, the actors are just falling apart. They are so frightened of the audience. There are just belly laughs rolling up to the stage from the audience. People are howling with laughter at every mistake.
所以她做了那个。在这一点上，演员们彻底崩溃了。他们太害怕观众了。观众席不断传来阵阵爆笑声。人们对每一个错误都笑得前仰后合。
And now any small mistake just takes on these-- any instigation for laughter is just enough of for this audience. And now the old people have given it up. Everyone has quit being nice. Now there's just this kind of frightening roar that comes from the audience every time there's a mistake.
现在任何小错误都带着——任何引人发笑的由头都足以让这个观众群沸腾。现在连老年人也放弃了。每个人都不再保持客气。现在，每当有一个错误发生，观众席就会发出一种可怕的咆哮声。
Well, what happened? At some point the audience turned and realized, oh wait. I realize what's going on here. This is a fiasco.
嗯，发生了什么？在某个时刻，观众转变了观念，意识到，哦，等等。我明白了现在发生了什么。这是一场惨败。
Yeah. This is a fiasco. And what's really interesting about a fiasco is that once it starts to tumble down, the audience wants to push it further along.
是的。这是一场惨败。关于惨败，真正有趣的是，一旦它开始坍塌，观众就想把它推得更远。
Oh, they get hungry for more fiasco.
哦，他们渴望更多的惨败。
Oh, yeah.
哦，是的。
If the play proceeded perfectly, they would be disappointed.
如果这出戏进行得完美无缺，他们反而会失望。
Oh, it would have been a grave disappointment had not been just one more mistake after another, one more embarrassment after another. Now the reason they're there is to chronicle these embarrassments. This is why I have remembered this play for 25 years.
哦，如果不是一个接一个的错误，一个接一个的尴尬，那将是极大的失望。现在他们留在那里的原因就是为了记录这些尴尬。这就是为什么25年来我一直记得这出戏。
Towards Act Three, Ira, the director had decided that she wanted to break down the fourth wall. This was cutting-edge theater, as far as she was concerned.
到了第三幕，艾拉，导演决定打破“第四面墙”。在她看来，这是前卫的戏剧。
Before you do this, I just want to explain. When we say breaking down the fourth wall, what we mean is the wall between the actors and the audience. Usually it's impermeable, but then there came a point in the late '60s, early '70s, where a lot of theaters-- basically, the actors would come out into the audience.
在你继续说之前，我想解释一下。当我们说打破第四面墙时，指的是演员和观众之间的墙。通常它是不可逾越的，但在60年代末、70年代初，许多剧院出现了这种情况——基本上，演员会走到观众席中。
That's right, and interact with the audience and break down that wall. So the idea being that you would get more in touch with the dramatic sense and the reality of what was happening.
没错，与观众互动，打破那堵墙。所以其理念是让你更深入地接触到戏剧感和正在发生的事情的现实。
Anyway, so in this particular scene, what was going to happen was that the Indians were going to throw rope ladders down from the balcony and climb down these rope ladders into the audience and move among the audience in their very scary, savage way and frighten us. Anyway, I know about this scene, because my friend David, who I went to high school with, was in it.
不管怎样，在这一特定场景中，本来会发生的是印第安人将从阳台上扔下绳梯，顺着绳梯爬进观众席，以他们那种非常可怕、野蛮的方式在观众中穿梭，吓唬我们。不管怎样，我知道这个场景，因为我高中时的朋友大卫也在里面。
So when David was climbing over the top of this balcony to climb down the rope, he lost his footing and fell to the floor from the balcony, a distance of about 15 to 20 feet.
所以当大卫翻过阳台顶端去爬绳子时，他失足从阳台上摔到了地板上，距离大约15到20英尺。
Oh my god.
天哪。
A good fall.
摔得不轻。
That's horrible.
那太可怕了。
Yeah. And he landed on both of his feet and sprained both of his ankles and, of course, curled into a fetal position and began to cry. He was really, really hurt.
是的。他双脚着地，扭伤了双脚踝，当然，缩成一团开始哭。他真的受了很重的伤。
Now, to appreciate the horrible moment I'm now describing, also understand that it's a Friday night. We are in a college town. And there is a volunteer fire and ambulance department. And in order to summon the rescuers from wherever they are, an alarm is sounded that can be heard for five miles. That alarm is located right over this theater.
现在，要体会我现在描述的那个可怕时刻，还要明白那天是周五晚上。我们在一个大学城。那里有志愿消防和救护部门。为了从他们所在的地方召集救援人员，警报声会响起，五英里外都能听到。那个警报器就在剧院正上方。
So the alarm goes off, OK? This is an air raid siren. It is so loud, you can put your fingers in your ear, and it's still hurting your ears. We're right under it. It can be heard for five miles.
所以警报响了，好吗？这是一个空袭警报。声音大得你即便把手指塞进耳朵里，耳朵依然会疼。我们就处于它正下方。五英里外都能听到。
And then, of course, three minutes later, busting through the door of the theater are these 15 firemen who are in boots, hats. They've got hoses. They don't know what it is. All they know is that they've been sent out on a call. And to add to the chaos, the director, of course, has flogged the actors that the show must go on.
然后，当然，三分钟后，15个消防员破门闯入剧院，他们穿着靴子，戴着帽子。他们拿着水管。他们不知道发生了什么。他们只知道自己是被派来出警的。更让混乱加剧的是，导演当然还在训斥演员，说演出必须继续。
No matter what.
无论如何。
No matter what. So while all of this is happening-- and several people are attending to David. And other people have just now decided that since the firemen are here, he's going to be fine. They can start laughing. And now the audience has just completely lost control.
无论如何。所以当这一切发生时——有些人正在照料大卫。另一些人现在认为，既然消防员都在这里了，他会没事的。他们可以开始笑了。现在观众已经完全失去了控制。
People are standing up in their seats and shouting for more. They want blood. At this point, people are actually injured in the production. And they want more. Somehow, that's how this entire play ended.
人们在座位上站起来大喊要更多。他们想要见血。此时，甚至有参与演出的人真的受伤了。但他们想要更多。不知怎么的，这出戏就是这样结束的。
What's interesting about that this as a fiasco, I feel like the thing it makes me understand about fiascoes, is that the fiasco itself is an altered state. That is, all the normal rules are off. You have left the normal rules of how the audience is going to interact with the actors.
关于这作为一场惨败，有趣的是，我觉得它让我明白的一点是，惨败本身是一种改变的状态。也就是说，所有的正常规则都不适用了。你已经离开了观众与演员互动方式的正常规则。
Right. I've never seen a production like this. And I've never seen an audience collapse like this.
对。我从未见过这样的制作。我也从未见过观众像这样崩溃。
See, but I wonder, when you think about what people go to theater for, what kind of release people want, people want an experience that will take them out of themselves. We all want an experience that would take us out of ourselves and into another place in another reality. And it sounds like this production, even though it was a fiasco-- in fact, because it was a fiasco-- was more successful at that than any conventional play could be.
看，但我怀疑，当你思考人们为什么去剧院，人们想要什么样的释放时，人们想要一种能让他们超越自我的体验。我们都想要一种能将我们带离自我，带入另一个时空、另一种现实的体验。听起来这场演出，尽管它是一场惨败——事实上，正因为它是一场惨败——比起任何传统的戏剧，它在这方面都更成功。
Well, see, I have to disagree with you there. I think the old theater critics, the ancients, would say that the reason you go to the theater and to see a great production is to be, I think the word these used to use is "transported." The idea being that you would be lifted away from your animal nature and into these higher, more spiritual realms, or get in touch with these greater, tragic emotions, right? But of course, what happened here was the exact opposite. We got transported directly in touch with our animal being.
嗯，在这点上我必须不同意你的看法。我认为老一辈的戏剧评论家，那些古人们，会说你去剧院看一场伟大的演出，目的是为了——我想他们以前用的词是——“被传送”。其理念是你会被从动物本性中提炼出来，进入这些更高尚、更精神的领域，或者接触到这些更伟大的悲剧情感，对吧？但当然，这里发生的是完全相反的事情。我们被传送到了直接接触我们动物本性的地方。
Our baser selves.
我们卑劣的自我。
Right. But that's almost as rare, if not more so, than a great production.
对。但这几乎和一场伟大的演出一样罕见，甚至更罕见。
Jack Hitt. He normally writes for The New York Times Magazine and The New Yorker.
杰克·希特。他通常为《纽约时报》杂志和《纽约客》撰稿。
[MUSIC - "I WON'T GROW UP" BY RICKIE LEE JONES]
[音乐 - 瑞奇·李·琼斯演唱的《我不会长大》]
Act Two, What We Wanted To Do. With some fiascoes, all social order breaks down. With others, a thing that you're trying to create simply refuses to be created. This next fiasco falls into that second category. Ron Carlson wrote this story. Jeff Dorchen reads it.
第二幕，我们想要做的事。对于某些惨败，所有的社会秩序都会瓦解。对于另一些，你试图创造的东西 simplemente 拒绝被创造出来。下一个惨败属于第二类。罗恩·卡尔森写了这个故事。杰夫·多琴朗读。
What we wanted to do was spill boiling oil onto the heads of our enemies as they attempted to bang down the gates of our village. But, as everyone now knows, we had some problems, primarily technical problems, that prevented us from doing what we wanted to do the way we had hoped to do it. What we're asking for today is another chance.
我们想要做的是，将沸油泼向那些试图撞开我们村门的敌人的头上。但是，正如现在每个人都知道的那样，我们遇到了一些问题，主要是技术问题，阻止了我们按照预想的方式去做我们想做的事。今天我们请求再给一次机会。
There has been so much media attention to this boiling oil issue that it is time to clear the air. There's a great deal of pressure to dismantle the system we have in place and bring the oil down off the roof. This would be a mistake.
媒体对沸油问题的关注太多了，现在是时候澄清一下了。有很大的压力要求拆除我们现有的系统，把油从屋顶上搬下来。这将是一个错误。
Yes, there were problems last month during the Visigoth raid. But as I will note, these are easily remedied. From its inception, I have been intimately involved with the boiling oil project-- research, development, physical deployment. I also happened to be team leader on the roof last month when we had occasion to try the system during the Visigoth attack about which so much has been written.
是的，上个月在西哥特人突袭期间确实出了问题。但正如我将指出的，这些都是很容易补救的。从项目启动之初，我就密切参与了沸油项目——研究、开发、物理部署。上个月当我们在西哥特人攻击期间有机会尝试该系统时，我恰好也是屋顶上的团队负责人，关于那次攻击的报道已经写得很多了。
First, the very concept of oil on the roof upset many of our villagers. Granted, it is exotic. But all great ideas seem strange at first. When our researchers realize we could position a cauldron 200 feet directly above our main portals, they began to see the possibilities of the greatest strategic defense system in the history of mankind. But at every turn we've met problems that our researchers could not, despite their intelligence and intuition, have foreseen.
首先，在屋顶上放油的概念让许多村民感到不安。诚然，它是异国情调的。但所有伟大的想法起初看起来都显得奇怪。当我们的研究人员意识到我们可以把一口大锅放在我们主门户正上方200英尺处时，他们开始看到建立人类历史上最伟大的防御战略系统的可能性。但在每一步中，我们都遇到了研究人员尽管拥有智慧和直觉也无法预见的问题。
For instance, how were we to get a 1,9000-pound brass cauldron onto the roof? In the end, the cauldron was raised to the roof by means of a custom-designed net and petard under less than ideal conditions. The Retrogoths and the Nilogoths plundered our village almost incessantly during the cauldron's four-month ascent.
例如，我们该如何将一口1900磅重的黄铜大锅运到屋顶上？最终，在不那么理想的条件下，通过定制设计的网和炸药，大锅被吊上了屋顶。在大锅升空的四个月里，Retrogoths人和Nilogoths人几乎不断地劫掠我们的村庄。
The cauldron's arrival on the roof was quite a moment. I remember it well. We stood by that gleaming symbol of our impending safety, a bright brass beacon to the world that we were not going to take it anymore. The wind carried up to us the cries of villagers being carried away by either the Maxigoths or the Minigoths.
大锅抵达屋顶的那一刻非常激动人心。我记得很清楚。我们站在那个闪闪发光的安全象征旁边，这是一个对世界发出的明亮的黄铜灯塔，表明我们不再忍气吞声。风将那些被Maxigoths人或Minigoths人劫走的村民的哭喊声带向我们。
But there we stood. As I felt the wind in my hair and watched the sporadic procession of home furnishings being carried out of our violated gates, I knew we were perched on the edge of a new epoch.
但我们站在那里。当我感到风吹过我的头发，看着那些被运出我们被劫掠的城门的家居用品时，我知道我们正站在一个新时代的边缘。
Well, there was some excitement. We began at once. We started a fire under the cauldron. And we knew we would all soon be safe. At that point, I made a mistake, which I now readily admit. In the utter ebullience of the moment, I called down. I did not scream maniacally, as was reported. I called down that it would not be long. And I probably shouldn't have, because it may have led some of our citizenry to lower their guard. It was a mistake. I admit it.
嗯，当时有些兴奋。我们立即开始了工作。我们在大锅下生了火。我们知道我们很快就会安全了。就在那时，我犯了一个错误，我现在欣然承认。在那一刻的极度兴奋中，我向下喊了一声。我并没有像报道中那样疯狂地尖叫。我向下喊道，很快就好了。我可能不该这样做，因为它可能导致我们的一些市民放松了警惕。这是一个错误。我承认。
There were, as we found almost immediately, still some bugs to be worked out of the program. For instance, there had never been a fire on top of the entry tower before. And yes, as everyone is aware, we had to spend more time than we really wanted containing the blaze, fueled as it was by the fresh high winds and the tower's wooden shingles. I hasten to add that the damage was moderate, as moderate as a four-hour fire could be.
我们几乎立刻发现，程序中还有一些漏洞需要解决。例如，之前从来没有人在入口塔顶生过火。是的，正如每个人都知道的那样，我们不得不花费比预想更多的时间来扑灭大火，因为强劲的高风和塔楼的木瓦加剧了火势。我赶紧补充说，损失是温和的，对于一场四小时的大火来说已经算是温和的。
But throughout this relentless series of setbacks, pitfalls, and rooftop fires, there has been a hard core of us absolutely dedicated to doing what we wanted to do, to splash scalding oil onto intruders as they pried or battered, yet again, at our old damaged gates. It was a little fire on the rooftop. It was of no consequence, a fribble, a tiny obstacle to be stepped over with an easy stride.
但在这无休止的一系列挫折、陷阱和屋顶大火中，我们核心的一群人绝对致力于做我们想做的事，将滚烫的油泼向那些再次撬开或撞击我们受损的旧城门的入侵者。屋顶上的一点小火并不重要，那只是个小插曲，一个可以轻松迈过的小障碍。
Were we tired? Were we dirty? Were some of us burned and cranky? No matter. We were committed. And so the next day, the first quiet day we'd had in this village in months, that same sooty cadre stood in the warm ashes high above the entry steps and tried again.
我们累了吗？我们脏吗？我们中间有些人被烧伤了吗，脾气暴躁吗？没关系。我们承诺过。所以第二天，我们村子里几个月来第一个安静的日子，同一群满脸烟灰的人站在入口台阶上方温暖的灰烬中，再次尝试了。
We knew, as we know right now, that our enemies are manifold and voracious and generally rude and persistent. And we wanted to be ready. But tell me this. Where does one find out how soon before an enemy attack to put the oil on to boil? Does anyone know? Let me assure you, it is not in any book. We were writing the book.
我们知道，就像我们现在知道的那样，我们的敌人是多重且贪婪的，通常是粗鲁且顽固的。我们想要做好准备。但告诉我这个。人们在哪里能找到关于敌方攻击前多久开始把油烧开的信息？有人知道吗？让我向你保证，任何书中都没有。我们正在写那本书。
We were vigilant. We squinted at the horizon all day long. And when we first saw the dust in the foothills, we fired our cauldron, using wood that had been elevated through the night in woven baskets. Even speaking about it here today, I can feel the excitement stirring in my heart. The orange flames licked the sides of the brass container hungrily, as if in concert with our own desperate desire for security and revenge.
我们很警惕。我们整天眯着眼看着地平线。当我们第一次看到山脚下的灰尘时，我们点燃了大锅，用整夜在编织篮中提升上来的木材。即使今天在这里谈论它，我仍能感到兴奋在心头激荡。橙色的火焰贪婪地舔着黄铜容器的侧面，仿佛在配合我们自己对安全和复仇的绝望渴望。
In the distance, I could see the phalanx of Visigoths marching toward us like a warship through a sea of dust. And in my soul, I pitied them and the end toward which they so steadfastly hastened. They seemed the very incarnation of mistake, their dreams of a day abusing our friends and families and of petty arson and lewd public behavior about to be extinguished in one gorgeous wash of searing oil. I was beside myself.
在远处，我可以看到西哥特人的方阵像一艘军舰穿过灰尘之海向我们走来。在我的灵魂深处，我怜悯他们，以及他们坚定不移地奔向的结局。他们似乎是错误的化身，他们那种骚扰我们的朋友和家人、轻微纵火和在公共场合猥亵行为的白日梦，即将在一片壮丽的滚烫油浪中熄灭。我简直无法自已。
It is important to know now that everyone on the roof that day exhibited orderly and methodical behavior. There was no wild screaming or cursing or even the kind of sarcastic chuckling you might expect in those about to enjoy a well-deserved and long-delayed victory. The problems of the day were not attributable to inappropriate deportment. My staff was good.
现在知道那天在屋顶上的每个人都表现出有序和有条不紊的行为很重要。没有疯狂的尖叫或咒骂，甚至没有你可能预料到的在即将享受一场当之无愧且姗姗来迟的胜利的人们身上出现的那种讽刺的冷笑。当天的事故不是因为行为不当造成的。我的团队表现很好。
It was when the Visigoths had approached close enough that we could see their cruel eyes and we could read their savage and misspelled tattoos that I realized our error. At that time, I put my hand on the smooth side of our beautiful cauldron and found it only vaguely warm, lukewarm, tepid. We had not known then what we now know. We need to put the oil on soon. It was my decision and my decision alone to do what we did, and that was to pour the warm oil on our enemies as they milled about the front gates, hammering at it with their truncheons.
当西哥特人靠近到我们可以看清他们残酷的眼神，我们可以读出他们那些野蛮且拼写错误的纹身时，我意识到我们的错误。当时，我把手放在我们美丽大锅光滑的侧面上，发现它只隐约感到温暖，温吞吞的，不温不火。我们当时不知道我们现在所知道的。我们需要早点把油烧开。是我做出了决定，而且是我一个人决定做我们所做的事，那就是在敌人在前门徘徊、用短棒撞击大门时，泼下温油。
Now, this is where my report diverges from so many of the popular accounts. We have heard it said that the warm oil served as a stimulant to the attack that followed, the attack I alluded to earlier, in which the criminal activity seemed even more animated than usual in the minds of some of our townspeople. Let me say first, I was an eyewitness. I gave the order to pour the oil and I witnessed its descent.
现在，这就是我的报告与许多流行版本不同的地方。我们听到有人说温油激发了随后发生的攻击，就是我之前提到的那种攻击，在一些村民心目中，犯罪活动看起来比平时还要活跃。让我先说，我是目击者。我下令倒油，我目睹了它的降落。
I am happy and proud to report that the oil hit its target with an accuracy and completeness I could have only dreamed of. We got them all. There was oil everywhere. We soaked them. We coated them. We covered them with a lustrous layer of oil. Unfortunately, as everyone knows, it was only warm.
我很高兴且自豪地报告，油以我梦寐以求的准确性和完整性击中了目标。我们搞定了他们所有人。到处都是油。我们淋透了他们。我们覆盖了他们。我们给他们裹上了一层闪亮的油膜。遗憾的是，正如每个人都知道的那样，它只是温的。
Their immediate reaction was also what I had hoped for, surprise and panic. This, however, lasted about one second. Then, several of them looked up into my face and began waving their fists in what I could only take as a tribute. And then, yes, they did become quite agitated anew, recommencing their assault on the weary planks of our patchwork gates. Some have said that they were on the verge of abandoning their attack before the oil was cast upon them, which I assure you is not true.
他们的立即反应也正是我所希望的，惊讶和恐慌。然而，这持续了大约一秒钟。然后，他们中有几个人抬头看着我的脸，开始挥舞拳头，我只能将其视为一种致敬。然后，是的，他们确实再次变得相当激动，重新开始攻击我们拼凑的大门上那些疲惫的木板。有些人说他们在油浇在他们身上之前就已经快要放弃攻击了，我向你保证那不是真的。
As to the attack that followed, it was no different in magnitude or intensity than any of the dozens we suffer every year. It may have seemed more odd or extreme, since the perpetrators were greasy and thereby more offensive. And they did take every stick of furniture left in the village, including the pews from the church, every chair in the great hall, and four milking stools, the last four from the dairy.
至于随后的攻击，其规模和强度与我们每年遭受的几十次攻击没有什么不同。它可能看起来更奇怪或更极端，因为肇事者浑身油腻，因此更具攻击性。他们确实带走了村子里剩下的每一件家具，包括教堂里的长椅、大厅里的每一把椅子，以及四把挤奶凳，那是奶制品厂最后的四把。
But I, for one, am simply tired of hearing about the slippery stain on the village steps. Yes, there is a bit of a mess. And yes, some of it seems to be permanent. My team removed what they could with salt and talc all this week. All I'll say now is watch your step as you come and go. In my mind, it's a small inconvenience to pay for a perfect weapon system.
但我个人只是厌倦了听到关于村口台阶上那滑溜溜的污渍的事情。是的，确实有点脏。是的，其中一些看起来是永久性的。我的团队整个星期都用盐和滑石粉去除了他们能去除的东西。我现在只想说，出入时请注意脚下。在我看来，为了一套完美的武器系统付出一丁点儿不便没什么大不了的。
"What We Wanted to Do" is from Ron Carlson's book of short stories called Hotel Eden. Ron's latest book is Return to Oakpine.
《我们想要做的事》摘自罗恩·卡尔森的短篇小说集《伊甸园酒店》。罗恩的最新著作是《重返橡木松》。
Coming up, man versus squirrel, specifically cop versus squirrel. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
接下来，人与松鼠，具体说是警察与松鼠。一分钟后，从芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台继续我们的节目。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, Fiasco, our own inquiry into the nature of what makes a fiasco, when you have left the world of mishaps, stumble, human error, and you enter into the much more rarefied realm of fiasco. We have arrived at Act Three of our program. Act Three, Squirrel Cop.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。当然，我们每周都会选择一个主题，为你带来不同种类的故事。今天的节目《惨败》，我们自己对是什么造就了惨败的探讨，当你离开事故、磕绊、人为错误的领域，进入一个更稀少、更精致的“惨败”领域。我们已经到达了节目的第三幕。第三幕，松鼠警察。
Well, human error is often at the heart of a fiasco. But what happens when you combine human error with, what we will call in this case, animal error? We have this story from a police officer in a suburban community on the East Coast.
嗯，人为错误通常是惨败的核心。但当你将人为错误与我们在此案例中称为“动物错误”的东西结合起来时会怎样？我们有这个来自东海岸郊区社区一名警察的故事。
There was nothing, nothing going on. Saturday night in this village. Really quiet. Super cold. And this call came over for unknown animal in a house. And it was on my post. It was about five minutes away.
没啥事，啥事都没有。周六晚上在这个村庄里。真的很安静。超级冷。接到了一个电话说家里有不知名动物。就在我的辖区。大约五分钟的路程。
So myself and another car were assigned the call. And we show up there. And luckily for me, it was another guy who was pretty new. So we walk up to the door with all our stuff on, the nylon coat, the vest, the belt, the whole nine yards.
所以我和另一辆车被指派去处理这个电话。我们到了那里。幸运的是对我来说，那是另一个刚入职不久的家伙。所以我们全副武装走到门口，穿着尼龙外套、背心、腰带，全套装备。
And the door opens, and the guy who is behind the door, he's about 30. I was 23 at the time. He's about 30. He looks like a broker, a lawyer. He's just really well put together, a nice guy wearing glasses.
门开了，门后的那个人大约30岁。我当时23岁。他大约30岁。他看起来像个经纪人，或者律师。他看起来非常干练，是个戴眼镜的好人。
He's wearing these, like, silk pajamas with a monogram, got my attention. And he's going, listen I'm really sorry to bother you. Normally, I'd handle this sort of stuff on my own. But my wife really insisted I call.
他穿着那种有缩写的丝绸睡衣，引起了我的注意。他说，听着，真的很抱歉打扰你们。通常我会自己处理这种事。但我妻子真的坚持要我报警。
So we ask him what the problem is. He says, well, we were having kind of a romantic evening down in the living room, and we heard a scratching upstairs. So I ran upstairs to see what it was. And it turns out it's coming from the attic. There's something up there. And it's just running around, knocking a few small things over. I can't tell what it is. It could be a squirrel, a raccoon. I really don't know.
所以我们问他问题是什么。他说，嗯，我们当时在客厅过着浪漫的夜晚，听到楼上有抓挠声。所以我跑上楼看是什么。结果发现是从阁楼传来的。上面有东西。它就在上面跑来跑去，打翻了一些小东西。我分辨不出是什么。可能是松鼠，浣熊。我真的不知道。
So the other cop that I was with said, well, you know, we really don't handle that. It's not so much a police function. But we do have numbers of these private contractors who will come in and they'll put a humane trap down, and they'll remove the animal for you. And it's really not such a big deal. But it's really not our thing.
所以我同行的那个警察说，嗯，你知道，我们真的不处理那种事。这不太算是警察的职责。但我们确实有一些私人承包商的电话号码，他们会过来，放置一个仁慈的陷阱，把动物从你这里移走。这真的不是什么大不了的事。但这确实不是我们的业务。
So right as he was in the middle of saying that and getting us off the hook, the guy swings the door back, and there's his wife, who was just beautiful. She was beautiful. She was probably about 26 or 27, but just really beautiful-- perfect skin, long blonde hair, great teeth, brilliant blue eyes, a really nice smile, just, like, beautiful and friendly. If she had said, eat this broken glass, I just would have said, OK, broken glass it is. That's fine.
所以就在他正说到一半想让我们脱身的时候，那个人把门推开，他的妻子站在那里，简直太美了。她很美。她可能大约26或27岁，但就是真的很美——完美的皮肤，长长的金发，漂亮的牙齿，闪亮的蓝眼睛，非常好的笑容，总之，就像，既漂亮又友好。如果她说，把这些碎玻璃吃了，我可能也会说，好的，吃碎玻璃就行了。没问题。
But she seemed really nice. So I was going to be, like, Galahad. So I just threw my arm back into this guy's chest, into my partner's chest. And I said, Mark, we can handle this. It'll be OK.
但她看起来确实很好。所以我决定做一次加拉哈德（骑士）。所以我一把将我的手臂挡在那个家伙的胸口，挡在我搭档的胸口。我说，马克，我们能处理这个。会没事的。
And she was just, oh, thank you so much. And she was really sweet. And I was, like, struck dead. So we walk inside. And she goes, I'm going to throw a pot of coffee on. And we go upstairs. We follow the man of the house upstairs. And we're underneath one of those trapdoors that goes into the attic with the staircase that folds out.
她只是，哦，非常感谢。她真的很甜。我当时就像被击中了一样。所以我们走进里面。她说，我要去煮壶咖啡。然后我们上楼。我们跟着房子的男主人上楼。我们在那块通往阁楼的活板门下面，那里有折叠出来的楼梯。
And we do hear an animal upstairs scratching away, just kind of scuttling around the floor. And there's definitely something up there. And it's making pretty good speed up, going from one end of the roof to the other. So I reached up and I took the trapdoor down. We unfolded the ladder.
我们确实听到楼上有动物在抓挠，就在地板上跑来跑去。上面肯定有什么东西。它跑得很快，从屋顶的一端跑到另一端。所以我伸手把活板门拉了下来。我们展开了梯子。
Now, I have this big, heavy flashlight, your cop flashlight, the four D-cells, the metal case, the whole thing. And I shine it up through the hole in there. And it's pretty black. I could see the rafters, but really nothing else around there. And I start up the ladder. Now, the guy who owned the house is standing almost directly underneath me, just to the side of the ladder, looking straight up at me. And my partner's at the base of the ladder, right behind me.
现在，我有这个大而沉重的手电筒，就是那种警察用的手电筒，四个D号电池，金属外壳，全套的东西。我透过那个洞往上照。里面很黑。我能看到椽子，但真的看不到周围的其他东西。我开始爬梯子。现在，屋主正站在我下方几乎正下方，就在梯子旁边，直直地看着我。我的搭档就在我身后的梯子底部。
So just before I stuck my head through this black hole, I just kind of paused. I crunched my body up underneath, because I'm realizing, gee, I don't know where this thing is. The second we pulled down the trapdoor, all noise upstairs just ceased.
所以就在我把头伸进这个黑洞之前，我停了一下。我身体缩在下面，因为我意识到，天哪，我不知道这东西在哪。我们拉下活板门的那一刻，楼上所有的噪音都停止了。
So I was kind of nervous. And I was like, well, I look like an idiot just crouched up here on the top of the ladder. So I took the flashlight, and I just popped my head up, turned the light on again.
所以我有点紧张。心想，我缩在梯子顶上看起来像个白痴。所以我拿起手电筒，再次把头探了上去，打开灯。
And about six inches from the front of my face was this squirrel at eye level with me, kind of reared back on its legs. And I swear, from where I was standing, it looked Godzilla. It just scared the heck out of me. I thought, it's a squirrel. It's going to hiding somewhere. It's going to be terrified of me. It was six inches away from me.
离我脸部前方大约六英寸的地方，这只松鼠和我平视，后腿站立着。我发誓，从我站的角度看，它看起来像哥斯拉。它真的把我吓坏了。我心想，这只是一只松鼠。它会躲到什么地方去的。它会怕我怕得要死。它离我就六英寸。
And it really startled me. So I kind of went, ah, and jump back. And the flashlight slips out of my hands. And it's heavy. And it falls directly onto the nose of the guy who's looking straight up at me. And I don't think it broke it, but it did some damage. And his hands went up to his face, blood just starting pouring out between his hands.
它真的吓了我一跳。所以我喊了一声，啊，跳了回来。手电筒从我手中滑落。它很重。它直接掉在那个正直视着我的家伙的鼻子上。我不认为它把它弄断了，但确实造成了一些伤害。他的手捂住脸，血顺着手指缝流了出来。
This is the homeowner.
这是房主。
This is the homeowner. I lose my balance and fall backwards, directly onto my partner. And I just pancake him. We're both on our backs. He's on his back. I'm on his stomach on my back, scuttling around like a beetle trying to get up in this really narrow hallway. It's a mess.
这是房主。我失去平衡摔向后方，直接砸在我的搭档身上。我像煎饼一样把他压扁了。我们俩都四脚朝天。他躺在背上。我趴在他的肚子上，像甲虫一样在这个非常狭窄的走廊里挣扎着想爬起来。一团乱。
The squirrel, while we're floundering around in the hallway, jumps down the stairs-- boink, boink, boink-- lands on me, and takes off down the stairs.
我们挣扎时，松鼠跳下楼梯——咚，咚，咚——落在我的身上，然后冲下楼梯。
How undignified.
多失态啊。
It was terrible. It was terrible. So we're wondering, gee, where is the squirrel? And right at that second, the woman who lived there, you hear her scream. So my partner goes, well, we found the squirrel. It's wherever she is.
太糟糕了。太糟糕了。所以我们在想，天哪，松鼠在哪？就在那一秒，住在那里女人的尖叫声传来。所以我搭档说，嗯，我们找到松鼠了。它无论在哪她都在哪。
So we go running downstairs. And the squirrel had come into the living room where they had been having their romantic evening. They a fire going. They had pillows arranged around one corner of the couch next to the fire. And they had champagne flutes out. Nice house, really nice, I mean, it just smelled brand new-- new carpeting, new rugs, new paint. They hadn't been there for that long.
所以我们跑下楼去。松鼠跑进了客厅，他们刚才在那里过浪漫的夜晚。他们点着火。他们在沙发旁边靠近火堆的角落里摆放着枕头。他们摆着香槟杯。漂亮的房子，真的很漂亮，我是说，闻起来简直像全新的一样——新的地毯，新的挂毯，新的油漆。他们搬进来没多久。
So the squirrel, when it bolted down the staircase, took off into the living room and ran underneath the couch for cover. So we run downstairs. This guy is bleeding all over the place on his carpets. His wife looks, and says, what have you done to my husband? I start going, oh, it was an accident. And then I just stop in mid-sentence. What's the point? We've only been there about two minutes.
所以松鼠从楼梯跑下来时，冲进客厅，钻到沙发底下躲起来。我们跑下楼。这家伙的地毯上到处都是血。他的妻子看着，说，你们对我丈夫做了什么？我开始说，哦，这只是个意外。然后我语塞了。有什么意义呢？我们才在那里待了两分钟。
So the squirrel is underneath the couch. And my partner is going, let's get out of here. This is just-- it's not going well. So I'm not beaten yet. I always have another idea.
松鼠在沙发下面。我的搭档说，离开这里吧。这真的是——进展不顺。所以我还没认输。我总有另一个想法。
So the squirrel is under this couch, which is in the middle of the room. So I have this bright idea. Why don't we move the furniture away from one of the corners? And we'll put the couch in the corner. And the squirrel will probably move along with the couch, because it's the only cover available to it. And once we get into the corner, we'll only have two open sides of the couch to worry about. So we did that.
所以松鼠在沙发底下，而沙发在房间中间。我有一个绝妙的主意。为什么我们不把家具从一个角落移开？把沙发挪进那个角落。松鼠可能会随着沙发移动，因为那是它唯一的掩体。一旦我们进了角落，我们就只需要处理沙发的两个开口侧面了。所以我们那样做了。
That is so tactical.
这太有战术了。
Yes. Yeah, I was very proud of myself at that instant. But you know. I asked her for a box. And she says, sure, we've got boxes. We just moved in. We have nothing but boxes. She runs out to the garage, and she comes back with a box. And the box is long enough. And it fits across the entire short side of the couch, where the armrest would be.
是的。是的，那一瞬间我很为自己骄傲。但你知道。我向她要一个盒子。她说，当然，我们有盒子。我们刚搬进来。我们全是盒子。她跑到车库，拿回来一个盒子。那个盒子足够长。它刚好横跨沙发较短的一侧，也就是扶手所在的地方。
So I start sweeping underneath the couch with my nightstick, trying to move the squirrel toward the box, figuring we'll capture it and just get rid of it. And we'll be out of here. And there'll be no more mayhem.
所以我开始用警棍在沙发下扫，试图把松鼠往盒子的方向赶，心想我们把它抓获然后把它赶走就行了。我们就可以离开这里了。不会有更多混乱了。
So it's actually working very well. And the squirrel is moving down along. You can hear it. It's chittering. And I'm trying not to hurt it. I'm nervous about the thing. It might bite me. I don't want to hurt it, really. It's just an animal.
所以这实际上进行得非常好。松鼠正沿着那边跑。你可以听到它。它在尖叫。我试着不伤害它。我对这东西感到紧张。它可能会咬我。我真的不想伤害它。它只是个动物。
So I'm moving it along, and everything's going very well. And then with about eight inches to go, I took one more swipe, and the thing just bolted out from underneath the couch. It was lined with tassels. I couldn't really see under the couch. It bolted out from underneath the couch and ran directly into the fireplace, which is about three feet away. The fireplace was directly ahead of it, and it ran into the fire and caught on fire, and ran directly back out and directly back under the couch.
所以我把它往前赶，一切都很顺利。然后在离目标只有八英寸的时候，我又扫了一下，这东西直接从沙发底下窜了出来。它下面有一圈流苏。我根本看不清沙发下面。它从沙发底下窜了出来，直接跑进了大约三英尺外的壁炉里。壁炉就在它前方，它跑进了火里，着了火，又直接跑出来钻回了沙发底下。
Is it on fire?
它着火了吗？
It was on fire. Yeah, the tail, the bushy fur, the whole bit. I mean, it wasn't, like, flaming or anything. But it was smoking. And there was a little bit of fire coming off the tail. So it runs back under the couch. And the couch catches on fire in seconds-- I mean, in seconds. It must have had dust under there or something else. But it just caught on fire immediately.
它着火了。是的，尾巴，毛茸茸的皮，全部部分。我的意思是，它并不是那种着大火，但它在冒烟。而且尾巴上有一点火星。所以它跑回沙发底下。沙发几秒钟内就着火了——我是说几秒钟。下面肯定有灰尘或其他东西。但它确实立即着火了。
And my partner and I just don't even talk. We just grab the couch, heave it upside down. And now there's plenty of oxygen for the fire to really get going. And it starts up. And we're patting it out. And it's sort of getting away from us.
我和我搭档连话都没说。我们抓住沙发，直接掀了个底朝天。现在有充足的氧气让火势真正蔓延开来。火烧起来了。我们在拍打火。它有点失控了。
So we grab the only thing that's really available. And those are these really nice silk pillows. And we have one in each hand, the both of us. And we're just windmilling away at this fire on the couch. And we put it out. But it's smoking terribly. And it was a disaster.
所以我们抓起手边唯一的东西。那就是那些非常漂亮的丝绸枕头。我们俩一人手里拿一个。我们正像风车一样拍打沙发上的火。我们把它扑灭了。但它冒着严重的烟。那是一场灾难。
The couch is upside down. The bottom of it is burnt. The house is filling with smoke from the couch. The squirrel, when it went under the couch, in its death throes, just latched onto the bottom of the couch. It's like this smoking piece of gristle underneath the couch, latched on there with its claws. And we're pounding, smearing it all over the place. The smoke alarms are firing away. The guy's standing with handkerchiefs and paper towels up around his nose, which is still bleeding. His pajamas are a mess. They're covered with blood, the front of them.
沙发底朝天了。底部烧焦了。房子里满是从沙发冒出来的烟。松鼠钻进沙发底下时，在死前的最后挣扎中，紧紧抓住了沙发底部。就像那沙发下面粘着一块冒烟的碎肉，用爪子紧紧抓在那里。我们在捶打，把它抹得到处都是。烟雾报警器响个不停。那家伙站在那里，用手帕和纸巾捂着鼻子，鼻子还在流血。他的睡衣一团糟。上面全是血，前面全是。
And we finally get the fire out. And we're both completely red, sweating, because we're dressed for, like, zero degree weather. And it's hot there by the fire. We're mortified. The house is full of smoke.
我们终于把火扑灭了。我们俩完全满脸通红，流着汗，因为我们穿着那种零度天气用的衣服。火堆旁很热。我们丢脸死了。房子里全是烟。
The wife just looks around and just starts to cry. She goes, what have you done? What have you done to my house? You could see her just clicking things off on her fingers. OK, the dead squirrel, ruined pillows, need a new couch, the walls are covered with soot, the fire alarms are going off, my husband's disfigured. And then she really kind of just lost it.
妻子只是环顾四周，开始哭。她说，你们做了什么？你们对我的房子做了什么？你可以看到她正在用手指清点东西。好的，死松鼠，枕头毁了，需要买个新沙发，墙上全是烟灰，火灾报警器在响，我丈夫破相了。然后她真的崩溃了。
And he was just looking at us and shaking his head, like he couldn't believe that these two idiots showed up and did this to his house over nothing, really. And he just goes, you know, you really haven't done anything wrong. I can't point to any one thing that you did that I have a reason to get angry about. You really haven't done anything wrong. I mean, we did call you. But I just, I can't thank you for this. They call for a squirrel. They end up with $3,000, $4,000 worth of damage and a broken nose. And this is all within about five minutes.
而他只是看着我们，摇着头，好像不敢相信这两个白痴出现后，为了一个实际上什么都不是的东西，把他的房子搞成了这样。他只是说，你知道，你们真的没做错什么。我指不出任何你们做错的事情，让我有理由生气。你们真的没做错什么。我是说，确实是我们报的警。但我只是，我没法为此感谢你们。他们报警抓一只松鼠。最终导致价值3000、4000美元的损失和一个断掉的鼻子。而这一切发生在大约五分钟内。
Could that have happened to you now, 13 years later?
现在，13年后，这种事还会发生在你们身上吗？
There's always a new mistake to be made. I don't think I would make that particular mistake. I mean, you make plenty of mistakes. You make plenty of mistakes. That's just part of that job. You just try not to make the same one twice. But there's such variety that you're going to make hundreds, you're going to make thousands of mistakes, until you really get a handle on what you're doing.
总会有新的错误可以犯。我不认为我会再犯那个特定的错误。我是说，你会犯很多错误。你会犯很多错误。那只是那份工作的一部分。你只是尽量不要犯同一个错误两次。但有太多种类的错误，你会犯数百个，你会犯数千个，直到你真正掌握你在做什么。
And with police work, they afford you plenty of space to make mistakes. But there's things that just aren't your responsibility. If you get involved in things that aren't your responsibility, or that you're really not equipped to handle, or that don't have a specific plan, a plan that's thought through to a conclusion, you probably should reevaluate what you're doing.
在警察工作中，他们给你留有足够的犯错空间。但有些事情不是你的责任。如果你卷入那些不是你的责任，或者你根本没有装备去处理，或者没有一个具体的计划——一个经过深思熟虑的计划——你应该重新评估你在做什么。
Yeah, now that you mention that, that's right. You walk into the house, thinking OK, we'll get this squirrel. Like, how were you going to get the squirrel? What was the best case scenario?
是的，既然你提到了，那是对的。你走进那房子，心想好的，我们会抓到这只松鼠。就像，你打算怎么抓松鼠？最好的情况是什么？
That's a great question. I guess I was thinking that I would go up there in the attic and find this cowering squirrel and somehow kind of lure it into some kind of a trap. And then walk out with it and be like a hero. But as it turned out, it was a Pyrrhic victory for the squirrel, but the squirrel definitely won. The squirrel really kicked our ass.
这是个好问题。我想我当时认为我会去阁楼上找到这只畏缩的松鼠，然后以某种方式把它引入某种陷阱。然后带着它走出来，像个英雄一样。但事实证明，这对松鼠来说是惨胜，但松鼠绝对赢了。松鼠确实踢了我们的屁股。
That is not what you want to be saying at the end of the day.
这可不是你想在一天结束时说的话。
No. No. I mean, it took a long time to even tell people about it. I was so new. I didn't want to know what a bonehead I was when I first came onto the job.
不。不。我的意思是，即使是跟别人讲这件事也花了好长时间。我太新了。我不想让他们知道我刚参加工作时是个笨蛋。
Our interviewee, who asked not to be named on the radio, has been on the force for 28 years.
我们的受访者要求在电台里不具名，已经在警队工作了28年。
[MUSIC - "FOX SQUIRREL" BY MUDDY WATERS]
[音乐 - 泥水佬演唱的《狐松鼠》]
Act Four, Fiascoes as a Force for Good. George Clooney, Barbara Streisand, Jennifer Aniston, Vidal Sassoon, Jodie Foster, Alicia Silverstone, Brad Pitt, Keanu Reeves, Sharon Stone, and John Travolta, also George Burns, Bob Hope, Gene Kelly, Gena Rowlands, also Quentin Tarantino, John Waters, Nora Ephron-- Margy Rochlin has interviewed all these people.
第四幕，惨败作为一种向善力量。乔治·克鲁尼、芭芭拉·史翠珊、詹妮弗·安妮斯顿、维达尔·沙宣、朱迪·福斯特、艾丽西亚·希尔维斯通、布拉德·皮特、基努·里维斯、莎朗·斯通和约翰·特拉沃尔塔，还有乔治·伯恩斯、鲍勃·霍普、吉恩·凯利、吉娜·罗兰兹，还有昆汀·塔伦蒂诺、约翰·沃特斯、诺拉·埃夫隆——玛吉·罗克林采访过所有这些人。
She does big magazine feature stories for big magazines in the New York Times. But the very, very first big feature assignment she was actually sent out on was by a publication in 1982. The Los Angeles Reader sent out a very nervous, very youthful Margy Rochlin to interview Moon Unit Zappa. You may remember her, daughter of Frank Zappa.
她为《纽约时报》等大型杂志撰写大型专题报道。但她被派出的第一个非常非常大的专题任务是在1982年。《洛杉矶读者》派出了一个非常紧张、非常年轻的玛吉·罗克林去采访月球单元·扎帕（Moon Unit Zappa）。你可能记得她，弗兰克·扎帕的女儿。
She had consented to her second interview ever after the release of her runaway hit song, "Valley Girl."
她在她的热门歌曲《山谷女孩》发布后，同意了接受她有史以来的第二次采访。
In this little bit that she does on this song, she's using a lot of this language, this sort of Valspeak that no one had ever heard before. And it was considered really exotic. And so I was from the valley, so I was sent to go talk to her.
在这首歌中，她使用了很多这种语言，这种以前从未有人听过的“山谷语”。它被认为是真正有异国情调的。我来自山谷，所以我被派去和她谈话。
She was one of your people. Speak to her in your secret, private argot.
她是你们那一类的人。用你们秘密、私下的暗语和她交流。
Exactly. And of course, what is so touching to me is that I totally bought that. You're right. I'm the right person for the job. I'm going to go speak to her in the valley language. And we will bond.
完全正确。当然，令我感动的是，我完全相信了。你是对的。我是做这份工作的合适人选。我要用山谷语去和她交流。我们会有共鸣的。
So you get there, and you're a bit nervous. And the pressure is on. Which is, of course, the setting for a possible triumph or possible fiasco. And what happens next?
所以你到了那里，你有点紧张。压力很大。这当然是可能成功或可能惨败的环境。接下来发生了什么？
Well, what I noticed was it was a tense situation. I just didn't feel like it was going very well. And the mother was sort of hovering.
嗯，我注意到情况很紧张。我只是觉得进展不太顺利。母亲有点在那盘旋。
Right. Well, we have a recording of it, because you had a tape recorder rolling during this.
对。嗯，我们有录音，因为你采访时录音机在转动。
Yes.
是的。
What are some other hang outs in the valley, besides the Galleria?
除了画廊，山谷里还有哪些常去的地方？
Bowling alleys with big arcades are very popular.
带有大型游戏厅的保龄球馆非常受欢迎。
Like what?
比如什么？
Oh, I'm trying-- at this point, I'm sort of that rock bottom level that everyone can get at in an interview, where you're just saying, like, what's your favorite color? And she's trying to help me along.
哦，我正在尝试——在这一点上，我处于那种面试时每个人都会遇到的最低谷，你只是在问，比如，你最喜欢的颜色是什么？她正试图帮我解围。
Kirkwood's is gone.
柯克伍德的店关了。
It's now the sports center.
它现在是体育中心。
Oh, but it's the same thing?
哦，但是一回事吗？
Yeah, it's still very popular.
是的，它仍然非常受欢迎。
So we're seated in the den. And the mother made me coffee. But I was too nervous to drink it. But I sort of kept staring at it. And she kept staring at it. And I felt like it was pretty important that at some point, I better drain that coffee cup.
所以我们坐在书房里。母亲给我泡了咖啡。但我太紧张了不敢喝。但我只是盯着它。她也一直盯着它。我觉得在某个时刻把那杯咖啡喝光很重要。
And so what happened was Moon told me a joke. And I didn't see the joke coming. And right before she told me the joke, I had taken a big swig of the coffee, which was now cold. And when she told me the joke, I burst out laughing. And I started to choke. And so I pressed my lips together, so I didn't spit it out. I didn't want to do a spit-take. And the coffee came shooting out my nose.
于是发生了什么，月球给我讲了个笑话。我没料到那个笑话。就在她讲完笑话之前，我喝了一大口咖啡，那咖啡现在已经凉了。当她讲完笑话时，我爆笑出来。我开始呛住。所以我紧闭嘴唇，这样我就没吐出来。我不想来一次“喷饭式”。咖啡直接从我鼻子里喷了出来。
Shooting out your nose?
从你鼻子里喷出来？
Shooting right out my nose.
直接从我鼻子里喷了出来。
Are you OK?
你没事吧？
[COUGHING]
[咳嗽声]
Are you OK? Get your hands up.
你没事吧？把手举起来。
I was really embarrassed, but simultaneously, I couldn't breath. At the same time, I was choking. And I jumped up. And I sort of started running around the room, knocking things over. And I think that they didn't know what was going on. But the mother began chasing me.
我真的很尴尬，但与此同时，我无法呼吸。同时，我正在呛住。我跳了起来。我开始在房间里跑来跑去，打翻了一些东西。我想他们不知道发生了什么。但母亲开始追我。
She began chasing you?
她开始追你？
She began chasing me, because I was running from corner to corner, trying to catch my breath. And she began chasing me. And at a certain point, she got behind me, and she gave me the Heimlich maneuver.
她开始追我，因为我从一个角落跑到另一个角落，试图喘口气。她开始追我。在某个时刻，她走到我身后，对我做了海姆立克急救法。
Put your arms up. No, really. Seriously? OK?
把手臂举起来。不，真的。说真的？好的？
Let's do the Heimlich maneuver.
让我们做海姆立克急救法。
Well, I've been in the news business-- I've been a reporter for 20 years. And nobody's ever given me the Heimlich maneuver while I've been on a story.
嗯，我从事新闻业——我当记者20年了。在我做报道时还从来没有人对我用过海姆立克急救法。
Well, I always say that it's a benchmark. It's a very low benchmark. And I can do any interview. I can get thrown off a set. I can be cursed out by the subject, but I can leave and get in the car, and I can drive home and think, I didn't blow coffee out my nose.
嗯，我总是说这是一种基准。这是一个非常低的基准。我可以做任何采访。我可以被赶出片场。我可以被受访者咒骂，但我可以离开并上车，我可以开车回家想，我没把咖啡从鼻子里喷出来。
Now, what happened after that?
那之后发生了什么？
It was sort of like we'd all been in an earthquake together. And all of nervousness left the room. And suddenly we were three gals, just chatting. And I remember that I sort of hugged them both when I left.
就像我们都在地震中经历过一样。所有的紧张都消失了。突然间我们变成了三个姐妹，只是在聊天。我记得离开时我拥抱了她们俩。
Wow.
哇。
They were now my friends.
她们现在成了我的朋友。
It's interesting, because one of our criteria for a fiasco is that all social order, the normal social structure breaks down. And literally, that's what happens here. The normal interview stops. And the social structure of the moment completely changes. The mom gives you the Heimlich maneuver. And then, suddenly, it stops feeling like an interview.
这很有趣，因为关于惨败的标准之一是，所有的社会秩序，正常的社会结构都会瓦解。字面意义上，这就是这里发生的事情。正常的采访停止了。那一刻的社会结构彻底改变了。妈妈对你做了海姆立克急救法。然后，突然间，它不再感觉像是一次采访了。
Yeah. And I have to say that it was a very embarrassing experience, and it completely made me feel close to them. It was so interesting. When Moon's father died a while ago, I bumped into her somewhere, and we both burst into tears. I really felt like a little sister of mine had had a loss. The starting point was--
是的。我不得不说这是一种非常尴尬的经历，它让我完全感到了与她们的亲近。这太有趣了。月球的父亲前阵子去世时，我在某处碰到了她，我们都哭了。我真的觉得像是我自己的小妹妹经历了一场失去。起点是——
That moment.
那一刻。
--that moment.
——那一刻。
To me, the thing about it that's useful is that it shows the useful purpose of a fiasco. That is, when social order breaks down, that could be a force not just for chaos and for entropy and for evil, but in fact, that could be a force for good.
对我来说，它有用的地方在于它展示了惨败的有用目的。也就是说，当社会秩序瓦解时，那可能不仅仅是混乱、熵和邪恶的力量，事实上，那可能是一种向善的力量。
Right.
对。
It can bring people together.
它可以把人们聚在一起。
Right. It was actually this huge success to me. I'd never been sent out under these kind of circumstances before. And I remember we beat the local paper. The Herald Examiner followed us a week later. And so we had the first story. And it was sort of considered the definitive one, because we had this glossary of terms that I had made or put together.
对。对我来说，这实际上是一次巨大的成功。我以前从没在这样的环境下被派出去过。我记得我们赢了当地的报纸。《先驱审查报》一周后跟踪了我们。所以我们有了第一篇报道。它被认为是决定性的一篇，因为我们有我制作或整理的一份术语表。
Of Valleyspeak terms.
关于山谷语的术语。
Of Valleyspeak terms. And then it was syndicated.
关于山谷语的术语。然后它被同步发刊了。
And most of the quotable stuff that you ended up using in your story happened after the incident?
而且你故事中最终用到的大多数可引用的内容都是发生在那个事件之后？
Yeah.
是的。
It happened after squirting the coffee through your nose.
它发生在咖啡从你鼻子里喷出之后。
Right, exactly. Exactly. It's a technique I don't suggest anyone trying. For years afterwards, Moon would send me postcards. And on the postcard somewhere would be a picture of a nose, and there would be liquid coming out of it. Sort of like my logo.
对，完全正确。完全正确。这是一种我不建议任何人尝试的技术。在那之后的几年里，月球会给我寄明信片。在明信片上的某个地方会有一个鼻子的图片，并且会有液体从里面流出来。有点像我的标志。
Margy Rochlin in Los Angeles.
在洛杉矶的玛吉·罗克林。
[MUSIC - "DAMAGE CONTROL" BY THE IDLE HANDS] [MUSIC - "DAMAGE CONTROL" BY THE IDLE HANDS]
[音乐 - “损坏控制”乐队演唱的《损坏控制》] [音乐 - “损坏控制”乐队演唱的《损坏控制》]
Well, our program was produced today by Nancy Updike and myself, with Paul Tough, Alix Siegel, and Julie Snyder. Contributing editors for today's program, Jack Hitt, Margy Rochlin, and Consigliere Sarah Vowell. Production help today from Dana Chivvis. Seth Lind is our operations director. Emily Condon is our production manager. Elise Bergerson is our administrative assistant. Adrianne Mathiowetz runs our website. Musical help today from John Connors and Damien Graef.
嗯，我们的节目今天由南希·厄普戴克和我本人制作，保罗·托夫、阿丽克斯·西格尔和朱莉·斯奈德参与。今天节目的特约编辑有杰克·希特、玛吉·罗克林和参谋萨拉·沃威尔。今天的制作帮助来自达娜·奇维斯。塞思·林德是我们的运营总监。艾米丽·康顿是我们的制作经理。埃莉斯·伯格森是我们的行政助理。阿德里安娜·马蒂奥维茨运营我们的网站。今天的音乐帮助来自约翰·康纳斯和达米安·格拉夫。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Torey Malatia, who walks into our studio at the end of each and every episode of our show to grimly assess the damage.
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。一如既往，感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚，他会在我们每一集节目的最后走进我们的演播室，阴郁地评估损失。
Dead squirrel, ruined pillows, need a new couch. The walls are covered with soot. The fire alarms are going off.
死松鼠，枕头毁了，需要买个新沙发。墙上全是烟灰。火灾报警器响个不停。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of this American life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带回更多这些美国生活的故事。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。